welcome to the next class there is the
evening class and this class is called
chess in the Romantic era so that means
a lot of gonna see a lot of sacrifices
okay from all times and so I found two
games today to show you okay so if we
have some time left afterwards
these are miniatures you know like nice
short games and afterwards if we have
time we'll do some puzzles so I want to
make sure you paying attention then
we're gonna do little test okay to see
how well you remember this so the first
game I have Jose told us against drawn
car ball they're not very they're not
really known chess players but played
more than 100 years ago in Barcelona so
it was just really really nice game
pretty game I see three
Knight f6 f4 name of the opening this
used to be very popular popular opening
back in the days in the beginning you
know like hundred years ago this used to
be very popular so what is this called
yes
Vienna game Vienna okay so I presume it
was in Vienna in the pitch pink in
Austria and then in one of the
tournaments so this should be for I
always thought deep I was the right
approach sheesh but again this game is
played in 1898 so back then there was
not that much theory
this is a move we should be six castle
we should before Bishop c4
this is gonna get really really wild
here in a little bit takes thanks and
white goes black was defy says you know
I'm gonna break that Center okay white
takes no he takes back to the night and
now we see things are started to hang a
little bit for white for example if you
take the pawn here this is gonna be a
blunder why should be more hands why is
this a blunder do you see so again you
have to look at the entire board the
entire board to see it what is the idea
Aashish Queen h4 check check antics do
neutral check and picks up the clip got
it
so he goes here that's why white didn't
take he paid Queen f3
now you can now take back with a pawn
because he's gonna drop a knight so he
took back with a knight now okay white
is like does it look like his opening
was a big success here so he's stuck
you know he's now on a pawn it's
difficult position sources okay let me
play this movers list again these are
not known players so we don't know how
strong they were but white that's some
very impressive combination at the end
so you might you probably will enjoy
this
so now black again is on this offense he
goes Knight G to check just he just
wants to completely destroy white but
now this backfires badly okay here if
black just plays Bishop e6 you know it
should be much better 96 you know back
is just better here so it takes takes
check and from the beginning it looks
like for a moment it looks like it's a
brilliant sacrifice wins another pawn
now check picks up the bishop but
there's a little problem here
after you takes this he takes here and
now he says where are you going now look
at that rook now can I go here takes
cannot go here Bishop is here gets
really messy now he goes check now the
King is under attack now white is gonna
be losing the rock
so he goes king f2 white black is like
okay not much I can do so let me take
this rock and now whitelist very clever
he doesn't rush to take on h8 okay he
doesn't rush to take on h8 here so what
does he play here calculate adi try not
to just say to move just see the whole
day
again you can take the rook no problem
but what else yes you could go rook e1
but then he has time to develop his
knight and protect the position a little
bit it's not so clear he develops the
knight and protects the position
that's right
correct he takes the rock now now we're
down to rooks
so here we need to find a way to mate
otherwise it's not gonna be very good
otherwise it's not going to be a good
addy Knight takes e5
Knight takes e5
that looks very strong I have to tell
you I think he took first he's trying to
go for a forcing line but I'm not seeing
a defense here anybody sees a defense
against Queen h8 this might be even
stronger
okay there's some c5 move but I don't
know if this is going to result into
anything but
okay
he took
and now magnifier probably wins - Adi
yes Ashish
correct correct okay maybe it could also
go to f5 by that thing just Queen f7 if
King f5 who can show me the mate yes
let's just mate it's always going to be
a mate in a position like this and if it
takes here
check
so that's why you went this way
you have made entry basically
whatever happens it's made entry
yes
look at that finish checkmate the King
in the middle of the board with t4y a
beautiful beautiful checkmate
nice miniature okay take a good look at
the final position now I'm going to test
you to see if you remember this 19 moves
okay
are you ready to review now okay let's
see first move let's go huh
demo'd opening vienna game remember
Vienna
yeah this Bishop c4 I'm not sure I think
it's a little bit questionable move
probably F takes e5 is better
yeah it's important because you cannot
take once again why can't you take a D
with h4 check picks up the wishbone
support ticks
which paid three I mean buck is better
here he just needs to take whites attack
seriously and play like 96 Bishop e6 I
mean if he does this there's no question
but Whitey's gonna prevail here and then
go along castle but he he just this is I
would call this adventurous play instead
of just playing properly developing the
pieces white gets adventurous and now he
gets punished for that go ahead check
huh
Queen takes a check 95 might be good too
but Queen eight is a forcing mate Queen
h8
okay King f5 let's to may check check
and mate Wow
if it goes King D 5 check check and mate
now
excellent nice work let's get to the
next game that I prepare to show you
this player you would not sure Paul
Morphy played in your lanes against
Eugene Rosso let's go efore so again
I'll show you together first
f4 again playing the Kings gambit okay
now pawn takes
Knight f3 g5 very aggressive approached
by black I mean this is Claire ball but
it's very very risky
so immediately h4 plate to attack 95
h6
tonight at 7:00
King of seven chemicals
Queen takes g4
Queen f6
we should check
develop
black king is stuck in the middle of the
board and white is just down a piece but
developing developing and threatening 95
checks so this is the correct way to
play now the threat is 95 so c6 is
played c6 is played
each five attacking the Queen
takes kd1 now threatening to play hooky
one so if I was a sacrifice to be able
to bring the rookin c5 again block this
up a full piece and if you've managed to
develop his pieces he will be winning
here now Bishop J takes the piece back
maybe me why not queen g7 yourself now
they tried to move d5 attacking on the
Queen
and now we see a very nice idea here
let's see if you can find this idea and
I need you to also tell me the name for
this tactic what is the name for this
tactic aha and what's the name for this
tactic decoy decoy sacrifice sometimes
referred as deflection okay
decoy or deflection yeah now deflecting
the king from the defender
continue
we take bishop check now
Knight takes d5 look at that sacrifice
he can you cannot take back with the
Queen Bishop takes they've taken the
pawn you dropping the Queen so you have
to go here only move and and now you
have a very neat finish yes
yeah that's that's how Morphy played
back in the day now the first unofficial
I believe world champion they have a
world championship cycle or you know
they have you know unofficial yes yes
yes yes yeah whichever you prefer you
prefer this that's fine that's still a
checkmate okay
that is still a checkmate okay any
questions
okay let's review the game now okay take
a good look at the final position I
believe he played Queen c7 so let's put
it this way so it's a 17 move miniature
by Paul Morphy
okay ready all right let's go go ahead
yeah this Queen f6 are not shutting
Knight f6 is playable well what else to
do 990 struct already well I thought
that Bishop c4 here
I think Bishop c4 is the mole fish with
the current a little bit more modern
computers in this efficiency 40 can play
still extremely sharp but here you have
to because you're gonna lose the night
and if you lose the night you cannot
even take back it's got this share so
you have to
we see again I don't know why I didn't
play queen g8 here it looks like much
better move no Queen g7 sorry the Queen
g7 here
now deeper
Brooklyn da
okay
jeez
yeah now if it takes with the Queen you
just take okay
excellent
sorry yeah I like I like this line I
don't like to get involved with this
stuff it's to me this is too much I like
this define wolf here yeah because now
take and you play Knight f6 I like this
yeah i mean i mean i again i haven't
played too many games but i know this is
a theory and now you're just gonna take
with a nice so take take because there
were some players who play this actually
consistently so this is a theory like
this i think this is okay for i think
this is a very reasonable position for
black here to bishops interesting yeah
this is also very interesting takes
white basically has to take here and
then you have efore and you also take
right different yeah i mean that's what
i think they're all playable you just
need to do a little bit of work a little
bit of analysis you know then you okay
very good so let's take let's do now a
couple of more positions okay so this
we're not gonna be doing study so we're
gonna just do some hard hard positions
okay
okay white to play and win breakthrough
okay
so take your time and try to calculate
as many lines as possible okay it's
quite a lot of calculation you have to
do here okay
quite a lot so about seven move
calculation I want so I don't want to
move the pieces so I want to give you
plenty of time to do that okay right to
play and when you need to play like a
world former world champion Ruslan
ponomaryov against one you air one of
the top Chinese grandmasters seven was
calculated everything
she's always raising his hand
okay please raise your hands
if you calculate everything seven move
calculation
okay to students we have now Claudio got
it no cloud your hazard all right let's
see here
minute minute another additional minute
for you calculate please they're not so
many ideas you have in this position
okay
okay who wants to go for the answer okay
going up upon threating a deadly 95
deadly so he has to accept the sacrifice
sacrificing the rook you sacrifice the
bishop already now in addition to that
you sacrifice a rope you gotta have the
follow-up to make this work though
you're a draw we have a draw in the
pocket okay do we want to take the draw
or we push for a victory push how do we
push though that's the question how do
we push yes
Knight g5 look at that move threating
mate mate on threating mate on seven now
he goes here and now look at that
Thanks check
winning NT queen versus rook at night so
in the game he took one ua took took and
he was counting on this check enough but
now the check is met by cover up check
and the night even though a knight is
pinned this is still considered the
check okay even though it's pinned but
it's still a check and now black has to
sacrifice his queen which will lead to
winning position any questions
No all right moving forward now okay
it's black to play okay black to play
and win in this position okay so let me
flip the board this is a game between
two two players that the player with the
black piece is a strong grandmaster
Gupta okay so how did he manage to win
the scheme black to play and win white
is up Apollo it seems like he is good
you know well enough coordinated you
know his pieces are protecting the F two
squares it seems like he is covering it
yeah you have to calculate at four moves
okay your main line is four moves form
of calculation okay your main line
your main line is form of calculation
yeah
ashish is raising his hand always she
lets Dean calculate don't rush
again it seems like white is just very
compact and that makes it difficult to
break this position because he's so
compact and you know protects everything
but even in a compact positions you can
find tactics to dis coordinate his
pieces okay that's what this idea works
you this coordinate opponent's pieces
and then you take advantage of it
how did Grandmaster Gupta won this game
please raise your hand if you have the
whole ideas the whole thing okay
participants cloud you're in the back no
idea nosy but he doesn't raise his head
no usually okay anybody else no cloud
you you want to start Knight takes F -
all right that's correct start okay now
White has two options here rube takes on
I think if he takes with the rook what
do you play f5 and now this guy's cannot
move because the rook is hanging okay
it's the loose piece now it goes here we
take you cannot take with the night you
take only one gets take back with the
Queen and then F takes e4
okay
winning the game so
that's why he plays Knight takes f2
now what is the idea Clow do you have it
she knows it
huh eggs
Bishop III a very very nice move yes
a quiet move that sets up the move rook
d2 which cannot be stopped and all of
blacks pieces are entering now into the
game okay our black piece are entering a
game
and if you play can apply bishop the to
your PIN your quick cannot do any and if
you go Kinsey to trying to escape repeat
who comes in attack in the claim and
enough to ask any questions
so let's look at this position again it
looks very hard to break through but you
start out with his tactic ex f5 now wins
the game and if takes back for the night
tonight you sacrifice got it okay got it
thank everybody for coming and to see
you next time
[Music]